hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play ILDA
phone say so you guys told me what I
needed to do which was after I went
upstairs and cleared it looked
everywhere basically read all the notes
that was key that someone said I go back
downstairs and then I stand on that
thing that I was standing on before and
then it breaks I don't know why I didn't
think of that because I had looked
everyone else I just kind of stopped
there so I there's no save game mechanic
I gotta get in then get to that but I
know exactly where to go so I should be
fine
hopefully key word hopefully okay anyway
the house is transformed into block
flash never since no one could stay in
it much longer
because of the screaming and cawing
people heard all the time I will try and
do my best to find that will die very go
go go neat Keats key key first key first
came out load load load son San
Ildefonso speedrun that's what this is
absurd quick quick left brownie see
there's one note down here I know that
and then call god this guy's slow Jesus
balls look out slows guys come man
where was the note down here now
whatever oh I'll get it later I'm
already on my way up so I'll just hit
this upstairs and then clear out
everything on the top floor then I'll
come back down here and let's go someone
this no no no no no no no no must be
farther in or something I'll get it
later
I wait for the day when this turns to
the scariness because it wasn't quite
scary before I mean it's nice in that
it's kind of an abandoned house buddy I
mean the rooms aren't logical in any way
and it doesn't seem all that terrifying
and also someone suggested that this guy
is actually holding a camera and that
why he seems to be moving around like a
drunk badger but also someone else might
have pointed out that
Slenderman he's probably Slenderman
probably probably okay I gotta make sure
I get all the notes that's what's
important there's nothing up here
besides notes so I need to remember
where they was let's check his back area
here is that's a note no but there was
an empty drawer up there for no reason
for no reason was there a drawer there
okay was there anything back here uh
yeah you don't know nothin about birthin
no babies I remember that okay didn't
see anything there I heard a noise I
heard some lady talking about birthing
babies not knowing anything about it
I mean wants to know comes out of the
vagina like boom bang suddenly you got a
baby that's how I know right stork flies
out of your vagina isn't that how it
works just rock and then all sudden you
had a baby and a stork bare feet that
stork okay I'm never having any sounds
of first bleh blah blah I heard scream I
had never heard before he was very scary
this is another episode of medical
really bad medical advice with
markiplier I'm a role model oh boy okay
so that loud clock this weird bathroom
this little alcove here hi
okay that was the only note up here that
I remember let's see nothing else seems
to be here we got that already
jeez you're not required we get it you
don't know about the babies nineties
people need a little medical advice from
me doctor markiplier then I'll get the
teeth clear clean oh is that blood stain
always there probably probably this door
still locked yep probably see
oh sorry sorry
again possessed every time I try to open
a door just something takes me over just
good John
I am Slenderman so I'm just I'm just a
little just a little well trying to hold
it together because I am trying to be an
upstanding member of society and I'm
fetching wills and whatnot
that's what I do and that's why I am
trying to reintegrate myself into
society with very little success on my
dad okay it's not breaking yet I do kind
of look lanky and like Slenderman we're
calling dinner madam ever let's go away
to around got everything back okay
well that looks good well let's see here
what ah no okay going into the sewers
now ow
oh where are my long lanky arms girl put
my hand back home oh this looks good
shoddy masonry work how's your use cheap
burning materials for water for the
cheap brother materials and subcode
wiring those house wouldn't be falling
apart at rivers okay so I don't know
what we're looking for in the sewers
obviously a way out but other than that
I don't really know do I have a sprint
oh I do
we're not done did I just get that haha
Mather is dubbing chase I write
what the hell with that okay suddenly
things took a turn and I can run Albee
it fairy drum Kali just call me the
drunk Slenderman
drunker man let's see there's trend herb
and tipsy man oh no I gotta be something
like oh man what would be I don't know
and these these staircases are extremely
narrow I might add I've been feeling
something down here with me
I'd love to be scared concrete when I
thought that there was something behind
me but come on come on what you got game
what you got all bring it on baby I'm
ready for you
I can't sprint anymore why can't I
sprint anymore
I could sprint before but not now these
like Emma I'm not joking these these
rooms are hallways are very narrow oh
well whatever still don't know what I'm
looking for maybe a key to get to the
rest of the house I mean I don't think
that there would be a will down here why
would there be Oh No what is this
another electrical box that doesn't do
anything a big open area yeah you okay
there you got something in your throat
you don't sound too good man oh I can
only oh hello what's this then it seems
yeah
Locke just like everything else well
this is a that is a weird way of running
man but hey you do your thing I'll do
I'll just let you go at it hahahaha oh
man I love it so funny so comical I
guess you've never really seen
Slenderman run so I guess this is all
he's got
what done why hey wait a minute
I see I'm breaking the game here but I
see through the levels so maybe that
conclude me into where I need to go hang
on remember pirate um I don't see
anything particularly useful so I don't
think that's gonna help me
okay let's go down let's see what's down
here Gooden could be something scary
maybe something scary maybe maybe
anything come on jump out at me do a
scream in the distance
give me some come on give it to me baby
uh-huh uh-huh give it to me baby uh-huh
uh-huh oh no I know I just all my fan
girls just went crazy
give it to me baby uh-huh uh-huh
anything nothing whole lot of nothing
I'm gonna be wandering around doing my
freaky run here you raise both arms in
unison that's how you're supposed to run
there's gotta be some there's gotta be
what am I missing
I'm just a series of long very narrow
and no I haven't seen anyone else
playing it so I don't know what to do
besides what you guys have told me
that's all I know is that a spot of
blood maybe nah blinking light I got
nothing
oh I thought that was something it'll
almost look like a figure but not quite
okay this looks familiar I think I went
down that way so let's go down this way
huh huh
okay that's locked but this is another
narrow very Scott's coughing up a storm
hmm
maybe he's being infected with some
terrifying virus of sorts No
tell me tell me tell me what to do
give me a reason to run oh this is
ridiculous
no I've been here I'm been here this is
just another way to go for the thingy
I'll barrier closed down here nothing
that's right I've been here this isn't
this is not helping me wait did I go
down that little alcove there was there
anything down there I remember yeah I've
been down there okay I gotta go back I
want to go back I can there was a whole
bunch of other different ways that I
could have gone wait did I go down here
uh-huh uh-huh excuse me as God a be
something right some some what was that
thing that I thought maybe it might have
been chasing me what was that wait no I
went down there this is a way to go back
let's go towards that thing I guess
whatever was behind me maybe maybe
that'll clue me in to what I need to do
back up these exceptionally narrow
staircase is get up there you [ __ ] get
up there stop slacking off
Slendy man drunky man drinkie man
Dipsy man something with a drinker man
vodka man tequila man oh no just go
whatever your name is just go we got
places to be in ghost to discover hope
it's a super fine lady ghost scons goose
Alec okay I did I go down there I think
I came out of there so if I go down here
this should be new should be being the
keyword should be there's a lot of
things this game should be
oh come on get up there
this guy's so fricken tall his head
keeps banging on things above them can I
go in here no guy you [ __ ] a-hole oh
man this game's gonna give me a give me
an aneurysm or some I try swear I'm
trying to get here but nothing they're
not doing no do it not to scare it not
dude to scare scare really really it's a
nod to scary ah oh oh when God hello Oh
what the hell is behind me where's
Robert
I need to write this - keep saying the
scream is terrifying I want to go to the
surface but I don't want to go back I'm
sort of lost I'm here trapped in this
dead-end we heard the scream when Robert
and I were doing some maintenance and
something started to follow us what that
now that's what I'm looking for what is
starting to follow us oh wait get up
wait those don't die now there was
something there I fainted there was
something there okay yes okay good I
thought that was like game over I just
decided to cuddle up with that dead body
for a second there okay so what is that
what is that I want to know what it is
before I run from it
sounds like an old Graham I'll screaming
up a storm but what is it what is it
wooly balls whoa whoa that is cool it
looked like a made what was that whoa I
fainted again I don't know why when I
faint it doesn't nibble my face off but
now we're on to something now we are on
to something and I am I don't know how
I'm gonna get past her haha okay let's
go , where are you doing screaming ha ha
now that I actually found the note I
could probably make some progress but
damn that probably went through all of
the other levels without even knowing
that I needed to do that ok what is this
this is where I dropped in correct okay
that's where I dropped in lish splash
splurt split look okay there was a
Dorothy in this hallway
maybe it's unlocked now maybe that sort
of triggered something maybe a lot of
maybes not a lot of guarantees come on
nope still locked pass there's no way
I'm gonna know what's changed now that
she's unlocked whatever maybe I'll just
go cuddle with a dead body again
whatever whatever whatever let's just go
hmm go away lady don't make me faint
again you weirdo weirdo okay so now that
she's comfortably behind me I will make
my way down here again we got to go
deeper
you know remain oh haha these doors
still locked I don't even hear a
confirmation click and click Li let's
just move forward Bria hello
what's all that interesting so we have a
diabolical lady chasing us now always
good and now we can make our way through
these little alcoves here to try to look
for a way out or a way in or something
that we need I'm still not like scared
scared the atmosphere has been pretty
broken for me for a while I mean it's
it's not it's not like the greatest
atmosphere in the world and it would be
cool if I didn't just faint and she went
away I was hoping for something else to
happen there and what's with the like
arrow only a few areas I can actually do
this weird jog jump sprint I don't even
know what I'm doing it's so wonky but
whatever beggars can't be choosers when
it comes to speed okay did I did I go
down here I don't really remember I
think I did didn't I I don't know
whatever I just need a lot of room to
swing my arms when I'm running some some
dumb something baby
maybe a little some some aah
did I see that tool box before I believe
I did anything in there no wait a minute
I don't think I've been down here huh
this is different hang on let me go down
it was different there no hang on let me
go this way I it's a maze and I don't
know the way out so you're just gonna
have to bear with me for a moment while
I figure this Hello another dead body
perfect yes
I'm glad I came down this way
dude ah no oh now I can run through here
ah I'm sure scared where is she coming
from where she came from
ah lady wish you got lady huh oh now I
can't sprint did I get far enough away
from her that it didn't become an urgent
matter whatever I got a key I think I
don't know what the key unlocks but I'm
it's either this gate here or that door
upstairs I think maybe I don't know no
oh yes yeah making progress ah to prayer
so prayer come to prayer okay yeah we
can get out to do what I don't know we
still haven't found the will or did we
find the will I don't know aha key what
was the key to I didn't see ah whoa you
stay back lady there's no other way to
go I got a trick this or some hey witch
crying about okay I should seen that
coming she Xena come from the mile away
the maid is not very happy squeak would
you like to stay the night squeeze so
far it's getting a little better it's
getting a little better I'm gonna try
this on the first floor I think this
might be the first floor key don't know
why I'm not just getting out of here
that would seem to be a priority to me
but this guy's crazy slender man and
also he's really drunk so he's probably
uh huh whoa was that a lady she was fine
come over here brave
slenderman got some nerve for you maybe
that's what Slenderman is all about he's
just a drunk who has no social skills so
he doesn't know how to flirt with women
and he just sends up scaring them all
away or killing them yeah call yet
anything here houki I found a key to
what diabolical music is never good this
is more Gone with the Wind
hi whoa
hey calm down there don't faint don't
faint don't faint don't fit I am fainted
what's the point of even having a
monster if they're not a threat oh come
on
I fainted yes what kind of pans am i
deal with it bread to some way I cannot
faint or something oh come on pick it up
let's go we got to go seriously the
whole threat of a monster's taken away I
don't know if like if I let them get
near me if the fainting actually is
deadly but I don't know so far it hasn't
done anything okay that's just an alt oh
I could have gone that way to not run
into her I guess whatever I don't know
okay hopefully that will summon the
monster demon lady which is good just
what I wanted ah the last note something
really strange must have happened here
because I have found these words on the
wall before I painted it I don't know
where Mary is she has gone upstairs to
take some D to Mister LD Falls we have
to we have to go away fast but she is
still there even after we heard the shot
I wonder what might have happened ah so
the maid was shot that's what happened
maybe I don't know so now if the mid
walks the halls forever tormented in her
demon NICUs please
I don't know I'm talking about and I got
a way Hingham I found one last page that
means something else has changed correct
maybe I don't know I'm still taking my
sweet-ass time Oh could I go any slower
okay maybe the upstair I found i did
find a key correct so I can go the
upstairs room let's go there I found
that note
ergo something might have happened smart
ass why I got brain that's why that's
why you all watch me cuz I'm so
intelligent this is a long way to go for
a will as a favor I don't even know if
I'm getting like paid for this there we
go alright making progress almost out of
here there finally some ambience a
menacing bass line red lights whoa whoa
whoa is that close the door it's too
evil Butler what is that what is it
I can't bear listening to these wizards
I'm gonna faint maybe no not yet okay
what was that that was different
I don't know what that was okay let me
read this why did she leave me why did
she take everything away from me why
that must be mr. eel you found it you
found son mr. Alda found me really
fountain I have a message for you your
wife hates you and your kids deny you
even exist well this looks bad
hmm ha Sears it what kind of rooms are
these who would live in these conditions
how do you even get the bed in there I
don't know mr. Hill default mystery
Levon check the dates check the dates
what dates their dates on the wall
somewhere if so I was not paying
attention check the dates what do you
mean check the dates what does that mean
I see a ladder here what check the date
I don't know what the date is what's the
date I don't remember a date 19th Elle's
way in the beginning oh no I don't know
19 no 18 who's 18 cuz there's no 9 18 oh
god I don't know ah this is gonna be bad
Oh Han let me just sequential e okay -
okay four it's gonna hit it eventually
ha ha ha oh god no I'm so I'm so bowed
not gonna work oh god I don't know I
don't know just get me out of here give
me either
I don't know how am I supposed to know
was there another note that said I know
check the dates I need to find a year
maybe there's something written on the
walls maybe maybe hang on let me check
gotta be something gotta be something
some some some some time's up some give
me some give me some clue oh hello
that's freaky
some photo from from from Psalm in the
bathroom maybe new don't tell me I gotta
go back downstairs why don't I have a
journal to keep all these notes I'm
finding or better yet why don't I
collect the notes as I go that would be
ideal
sweet please tell me those in all 1st of
October so that that's not 4 digits but
it's closer I guess
it's 10 I don't even think there were
zeros on that Oh God whoa wait no first
of October that's right okay first of
October there were on the other notes
were they all like dated I don't know I
don't remember I got to go back and
check the dates damn it
okay one oh this is such a pain in the
balls pain in balls okay he's grabbed
the notes and get out of here where was
a note in here towards the back end of
this place I think maybe or was it I
don't even remember um no it was not
back here weren't there two notes in
here there two notes in some area I
don't remember where though oh I'm gonna
be here for days days did I miss
something here I swear there was I
thought I saw I thought there was no one
back here shut up unless you're gonna oh
come on why won't you run here oh man
I was in here duh okay seven one seven I
don't even know what a order it's in but
whatever uh there are two notes on this
floor so one in seven one and seven in
here no yes no those are door one in
seven one in seven know there was
another note here I know there was one
in seven one in seven one seven one is
seven
nothing in there yes I know there were
two notes on this floor fudge all right
fine ah oh yeah the first floor there's
a whole nother floor that I can get to
okay so if I get the floor and then the
basement or not the basement put the
floor down you don't know what I mean
this game is turning into a chore like
seriously this game has been quite a
chore I mean not bad eh a lot of work
has gone into it but quite honestly one
in a seven wanna see seven a one and
seven why couldn't I have just
remembered what dates there were okay
it's not back here
wasn't in this wasn't no that's where
the key was one and a 7 1 and a 7
ah and even the monsters have gone away
that's a damn shame
like I don't know where they went the
one in the top floor was actually pretty
interesting
oh no one in a 7 in uh 2 1 7 2 in some
particular order that I don't know ok
that was March the 7
April right so maybe two seven Sylacauga
to seven something one to seven
something one I can probably just guess
it at this point because I got the three
other ones
haha I don't know but I don't want to be
I don't want to be wandering around so
let's just get it and go wait no I can't
because I'd walk over the whole okay so
I'm going on this theory it'll be two
seven something one ergo I hope this
doesn't fail cuz the other note was
behind the pole I don't remember that
two seven something one that's what I'm
going for that's what I'm hoping for
so let's just gun it let's do this let's
win it and see the ending I like I got
nothing left to say I got nothing left
or do um this is just like the last bit
I'm hoping I'm hoping this leads to the
will if not um will be very upset okay
cheer sham it were Oh
Pass gotta be kidding me you got to be
kidding me oh you got to be kidding me
maybe it was May maybe I was wrong and
think it was March I saw em I thought it
was oh fudge or nutters oh no oh no okay
maybe the mystery number was on the okay
let me go by floor the mystery number
was on the first floor and on the other
one there was a two and then on the the
same floors this one there was a seven
and in here there was one so that means
yes yeah hahaha yeah okay alright
alright we're in the Attic
yes oh god damn oh wait oh my flashlight
just died somehow ha ha ha don't know
how oh come on give me some I'm so ready
my body is ready my
feel it yeah uh-huh
I picked up a gun how do I shoot it
bang II can I shoot - bang bang can I
shoot too / bang bang shoot him
shut up shoot him shoot him how do i
shut up sha Nam I press a lot of buttons
a lot of buns Oh
ooh okay wait what wait a minute
okay something's gone a little bit weird
there is no longer a door this weird
light is flashing and I've got nothing
to interact with things are going a bit
strange for me
on your knees or no press eat it no
Prezi nachos your son Tommy was gonna
show yourself there isn't even credit
music it's just silence like the silence
of my soul after the darkness finally
closes it around me okay I'm gonna be
blunt I did not like that game I did not
it was a chore the controls were wonky
the scares were subpar hi what are you
doing there let's go say hi oh no you're
not there okay
so hi I'm just being Frank I did not
like the game I was not that scared by
it I was more frustrated than anything
and the whole puzzle at the end would
have been solved with the journal system
if that could have been implemented the
level design was just all over the place
and things were not that helpful I mean
I want I want to find summer dreaming
qualities in that it looked like there
was a lot of effort put into it and I do
like the fact that people do go out and
try to do it but this game was not scary
at all
and I don't know the monsters could have
been so much better if there were there
wasn't that silly fainting mechanic like
I mean I understand that the game was
very tedious to get through and if he
had died without a save mechanic that
would have been very frustrating so the
fainting mechanic was like a solution to
a problem that shouldn't have been there
in the beginning so the monsters were
like not even a little bit a little bit
of a problem so I don't know I don't
know what to say about it I did not
enjoy it all that much but I do
appreciate the effort of the developer
you always got to appreciate the effort
I mean sometimes they won't hit their
goals or hit what they want no you can't
always reach your target but it just
wasn't there for me for me for me that's
my opinion I'm still just one guy you
all play it for yourself and decide what
you think of the game what you think is
more important than what I think cuz I'm
just an idiot buying a camera so anyway
that's all I'm gonna say about that so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
Oh
I do
but
yeah